on things like sending you know those
fourteen hundred dollar checks putting
cash out there I mean didn't that end up
contributing to inflation do you have
any regrets about the bills you passed
and how you structured them no
absolutely not because this that was
necessary uh for people to survive our
purpose was that it was inflationary the
Wonder but the point is is that when you
reduce unemployment it's inflationary
and the fact is is that uh when I hear
people talk about inflation as I heard
them there we have to change that
subject inflation is a global phenomena
phenomenon the EU the European Union the
UK the British have higher inflation
rate than we do here it's not the fight
is not about inflation it's about the
cost of living this is what they do they
pretend they're nice while you're voting
for them to control you please govern me
harder please I vote for you to take my
money